Six-year-old Jaden Hayes is counting on making you smile,...
...and then counting every smile he collects.
And taking pictures and documenting his smile experiment.
Can I get a hug, too?
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Everyone: from shop owners to tourists, even TV news anchors.
How big of a smile does that give you when you make other people smile?
Well, it makes me kind of really proud.
And I like it when people smile.
But behind this little boy's grin is a very painful story.
He lost his father two years ago.
And last Sunday, Jaden's mom put him to bed.
Both went to sleep, but she never woke up.
Now this little boy who's feeling such a loss,...
...is pulling his aunt in the summer heat in Savannah to spread some sunshine.
He was tired of seeing frowning, craggy faces.
Here, ma'am.
You did a good job!
Little Jaden is trying to be someone else's sunshine,...
...being the reason they smile.
Why is a smile a good thing to see?